we've already seen that a fraction like
9 can be interpreted as 2
divided by 9. let me do the 2 in the
same color as 2
divided by 9. that if we have a fraction
that it can be interpreted as the
numerator divided by the denominator and
this leads to all sorts of interesting
conclusions some of which we've already
seen and some of which are a little bit
new so for example if i had the fraction
if i had the fraction
7 7
this can be interpreted now as 7 divided
by 7 as our numerator
divided by our denominator and seven
divided by seven is of course equal to
one and this is consistent with what
we've already seen seven sevenths would
get us to a whole and a whole is the
exact same thing as one but we could do
things a little bit more interesting as
well
we could take something like
18 sixths
18 6
and realize that wow this is the same
thing as 18 divided by 6
18 divided by 6
which we know is equal to 3
is equal to 3. and we should do a little
reality check does this make sense that
18 6 should be equal to 3
well we could rewrite it we could
rewrite 18 6
18 6. let me write it make the sixth
that same orange color
that's going to be the same thing
18 is 6 plus 6 plus six and then all of
that
over six
all of that over six and then that's the
same thing
that's the same thing as six
over six plus six over six plus six over
six and i could make this
i could make this right over here in
orange and we've already seen or we've
seen many many videos ago that six
sixths just like seven sevenths these
are each equal to a whole these are each
equal to one and we can now view this as
six divided by six which is the same
thing as one so this is one
plus one
plus one which is of course equal to
three
but this starts to raise an interesting
question this worked out just fine when
because 18 is a multiple of 6 6 divides
evenly into 18. but what happens if
we're if we start having fractions where
the new where the denominator does not
divide evenly into the numerator let's
say we have a fraction like
over
over 6
23 over 6. well we know that we can
interpret this as 23 divided by 6
divided by 6 and if we actually divide
23 by 6 so let's do that so we divide 6
into 23
into 23. we know 6 goes into 23
3 times 3 times 6 is 18 and then when
you subtract you end up with a remainder
of 5. so we might say hey 23 divided by
23 divided by
6 is equal to 5 remainder 3
is equal to 5
remainder 3.
but that's not that satisfying what do i
do with this remainder this really isn't
a number here this says we go this is
just saying that we're going five times
and then we have a little bit left over
what we can do now is is manipulate this
a little bit so that we can realize that
this is a number and in particular a
mixed number so for example we could
start with a 23 over 6 and we could
divide it into or we could decompose the
numerator into one part that is
divisible by 6 evenly divisible by 6 and
the remainder so for example 23 over 6
we can rewrite as
plus 5
over 6
over 6. notice i decomposed the 23 into
one part that is multiple that is a
multiple of 6 and it's the largest
multiple that essentially fits into 23
or that is less than or equal to 23 and
then the remainder the remainder when
you divide 6 into 23 you get a remainder
of 5. you could view it as i divide it
into the remainder and everything else
and the reason why this is interesting
is because we know that this is going to
be equal to
18 over 6
plus 5 over 6
plus 5 over 6. well we already know that
18 over 6 is the same thing as 18
divided by 6 or 3.
so this is the same thing as 3. so we
know that 23 over 6 which is the same
thing as 18 plus 5 over 6 is the same
thing as 3 plus 5 6 or if we want to
write it as a mixed number we could
write as 3 and
3 and
6.